dans cette semaine un ou une invitée a
clairement tenté de pécho cyril
lui demandant à son numéro de téléphone
cyril très embarrassé a eu sept
magnifiques réponse je ne sais pas je ne
connais pas mon numéro
jour n'était pas mon numéro je ne
connais pas mon numéro où alors c'est
pas du tout ça c'est le maire de dakar
ne sais pas de qui vous parlez non mais
c'est parce que vous
vous ne voyez pas l'amitié entre les
filles et les garçons
numéro mais parce que je ne connais pas
c'est pas maintenant que je ne connais
pas mon bébé c'est le numéro de tous les
creux je vous demande mes droits premier
chef les trois premiers 06 78
mathieu est le mien je le connaissais
je le connais pas je n'ai pas mais non
je dois vous dire à quel moment vous
allez arrêtez de vous [ __ ]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]